Valentine's Day is coming up in February
people 2017 which means do fifty shades
darker on the exciting if you love 50
shades of gray I did which I so did I
love was not boring it was so sexy it
wasn't not very BDSM me at all I had
such I didn't struggle to stay awake
well looks like that Anastasia is
entering back into the abusive
relationship with Christian and fifty
shades darker they got a new director
here new writer before we talk more
about that let's just watch the actual
trailer all right Universal Studios I
mean I love this Universal
[Music]
he's alone during a celebration
okay get [ __ ] that last movie yes [ __ ]
Beyonce's voice they replaced everything
I have no idea what this was gonna
become I don't see how this can work
are you just gonna stand there gawking
yes it goes
baby
you
[Music]
you can Basinger
whoa do you think you're the first woman
who's tried to save him no thanks Miguel
thanks Miguel Cheers
hmm
now I know that fans of Fifty Shades of
Grey are huge fans of the real rejects
totally we are the total target
demographic the first half of this
trailer look like this is the exact same
thing we're gonna do it do over yeah
we're just gonna try it again this is a
gig Sloot a few things listen Chris
maybe a change the cinematography still
looks good
oh that shower scene looks sexy looks
swanky though I like that shower scene
something tells me that this time around
they might have more chemistry given the
benefit of the doubt granted we don't
really get much in the trailer I really
determined that I just feel like they
might have taken note of that these are
two talented actors I see pretty images
of pretty people I don't see chemistry
just yet well look how happy they look
in bed here don't John please I'm just
trying to be nice to the movie at the
same time it looks like it wanna be it
wants to be like eyes wide shut
yeah this is why I wish they would just
go full eyes wide shut with this like if
they did that like I would I would
almost be pleased they just threw down
because that was my part of the trouble
with the first movies like the first it
half-assed yeah like a quarter of an ass
in that me yeah I have friends who are
who are into you know BDSM it's a badge
on those guys and like it is a didn't
seem like it was in any way involved
with that community really like I don't
know well you see the thing about okay
the only sexy week they tease here is
the shower scene what I liked about how
that shower scene at least they were
showing us the brief images of it
was it did it look like they were trying
to go for like crazy cinematic sex scene
as opposed to what up like the other one
did with it's like non sexy montage this
is like weird images yeah like over
Beyonce's crazy in love slow renditions
they're weird like softcore like montage
Murray yeah this looks like they have
these two actors just get in the shower
and start like going for it
these movies are conundrums to me
because you have to throw down in the
sex in these movie then I don't feel
like they're free to do that completely
like this one looks like I haven't read
the book I'm not going to read the book
like the last 30 seconds were like whoa
I guess this is a thriller now like like
guys I know yeah the first ones
advertised this is an erotic thriller
that's about these two now it seems like
this please yeah what they're doing but
at the same time like you know part of
this is I guess this is like a ghost
movie that girl shows up in the bedroom
and I'm like is she really there and
then just vanishes yeah there's probably
just some kind of like you know
metaphorical loosen ation same girl who
was saying that she you know she's dopey
she like
Anastasia's not the only one who try to
change Christian yeah Hugo's she was
implying that she was that person too
I couldn't tell is it Kim Basinger plane
because I remember in the movie he
talked about how like an older woman
yeah was his dominant eye do you think
that's Kim Basinger it could be good but
I mean why else would you cast somebody
with a name I mean I think Kim Basinger
is a good addition to this to this movie
because I think Kim Basinger is like
good at that was like kind of sexy
erotic thriller kind of roles yeah I
hope her presence is a sign that this
will be better and not a sign that you
know this was the only role she could
get right now I mean this director has
done some pretty credible work yeah
that's what a perfect stranger okay
Bruce Willis Halle Berry Goodman perfect
everyone loved everyone loved it you did
a [ __ ] film called blank Gary Glen
Roscoe oh yeah if I'm worst ensemble
worst Pacino Jack Lemmon performance ABC
ass black [ __ ] totally that's what that
means
and then they had to change it because
they didn't want to get that and c7c big
clean house on their creatives and they
went with two dudes yeah that's right
Nick yeah they had this director Jake
James Foley
I love Glengarry Glen Ross that was like
20 long years but he did a lot of house
of cards he seems to be one
mein directors for house of cards people
wow that's a really widely respected
show beautifully shot show as well if
they taking notes of you know the
disappointment factors of everything
that like people were not happy with I
don't remember fans of the book being
satisfied with the movie well yeah and I
I saw the movie it's like I didn't hate
it but it was like it's just everything
was just kind of alright and then some
stuff was was unintentionally funny and
it just kind of came across as one of
those experiences where you didn't
understand what all the fuss was about
so I hope that they bring some fuss into
this in this trailer what I guess if I
were to say that things that appeal to
me were the last 30 seconds people
getting taken away in the cars and
someone chasing after them something
like someone's stalking them when it
looks like something more is gonna
happen than just them going Christian I
can save you know I'm [ __ ] up no but
you're [ __ ] up but I'm not [ __ ] up
okay you're not [ __ ] up but I am
because the first like minute of this
trailer was showing us that like okay
they're gonna get back together and
they're gonna try it again they're not
gonna be as crazy abusive about it I
hope this film capitalizes more on that
because I feel like a Phil from
Universal Pictures that wants to appeal
to the masses they're not gonna go full
heart are with it with the erotic part
of this movie they have to but I just
don't see them doing that they have to
make up with it with something else or I
feel like there's studio execs doubting
themselves being like oh the erotic
stuff didn't work so we should just try
something else instead of trying to make
the erotic stuff work it would be cool
if it all works in the end yeah I'm
probably gonna watch this movie Twilight
comes to mind I've seen every Twilight
movie in the theaters really I've seen
every single violet movie I'm probably
gonna watch this too because I just got
to find out like what deal this is one
of those morbid curiosity movies for me
like I went to see the first one I was
like I am going I made the decision cuz
I'm like this is not for me and for some
reason that makes me curious to see what
everybody's freaking out about I want to
see because they changed the writer up
they changed the director and I'm hoping
that allows them to take it in a
different kind of direction I remember
even the author wasn't satisfied with
the way the movie came out the first one
see I feel like these movies are kind of
doomed to be not entirely satisfying I
hope they can make up for the stuff they
can't put into this by making the story
better and for
giving us you know a thriller of some
kind like an erotic thriller because
that seems like I think that is coming
back a little bit but it's not like what
we get all the time so like a good
erotic thriller might be fun to do again
you know because it's been awhile since
Michael Douglas stepped on screen dr.
Hank Pym Hank Pym in the porn version
I'm a little bummed
just from a progress standpoint that
they completely clean house and got new
dudes to do this to dudes to helm this
cuz that's a little strange to me two
dudes I mean it's gonna be way more
womanizing yes I'm a little bit afraid
but also it's like you know they took
this thing that is a debatable book
already about you know what are the
connotations of this book what are the
sort of roles everybody's playing is
this kind of an abusive situation you
know and they let women handle that it's
got a predominantly female audience a
lot of women read this book and I feel
like it's a little bit weird to put it
in the hands of two older gentlemen
because especially if we're gonna make
it any better like it might become more
thrilling like like I said it might
become more of a thriller but I don't
know if it'll become any better yeah it
doesn't see what's going down to
Rockville or it seems like it's going
down conspiracy thriller that was the
whole draw of Fifty Shades of Grey
mm-hmm was like this couple exploring
the BDSM world you know the dominant
submissive world that was the intrigue
now it is trailer doesn't even seem to
have it yeah yes like it's the
indulgence in an abusive situation also
the taboo bonded and I don't really give
a [ __ ] enough about these characters
apply it to like really feel like I got
a clock in to see what the hell is going
on underneath this whole conspiracy of
all this other [ __ ] of Christians past
that never really quite intrigued me
anyway way it's tough like at the
beginning of the trailer forget the past
I don't even know what that's supposed
to mean this trailer I feel like that
just means forget the last movie like
that literally means hey that movie that
a lot of people do really care for well
we were doing it all over again totally
different I mean I feel Anastasia
character is kind of insulting to women
to be perfectly honest thing is I mean
like I again I haven't read the book and
I don't plan on reading the book but I
know a lot of people who have and and
they don't have very kind things to say
is this woman running after this guy
because she wants to change him and the
thing is I've heard over the three book
arc it's basically about a woman taking
this guy who's have
to this alternative lifestyle basically
making them a normal guy who settles
down really so it's like a totally
conventional story - about an abusive
relationship I know want me to be into
this because of how [ __ ] sexy the
book is and how like like how there's
like erotica in the book like there's
detailed descriptions of their sexual
activity in the book I don't know
anything about those other like thriller
storylines [ __ ] when I hear this I'm
just like man when I mean a girl in real
life who's in an abusive relationship
like a beautiful girl in an abusive
relationship and she's trying to change
the guy but that's impossible
no she's not going to change the guy
like it's just hey if you're a woman who
adversity watches in a situation like
that is not gonna happen vice versa as
well because sometimes it's kind of
reversed this idea that like oh yeah if
he if she see no theythey fall in love
and she could change him like what how
people still on board for that like it's
yeah it's [ __ ] up I mean this is how
women turn abusive relationships and
that's the thing is like I get the the
the titillating factor in if you're
reading those books there's something
juicy about reading about a toxic
situation it's a forbidden fantasy it's
it's a it's an arousing sexual fantasy
and I can see why somebody might want to
read that and if they you know
understand it the right way it's fine
but I feel like this just should have
stayed a book because when you make it
into a movie you have certain
responsibilities it doesn't seem like
they can translate this either true to
what it is or make it any any much
better than what it is it's like they're
locked in the middle of like we kind of
have to approximate Fifty Shades of Grey
but we can't put too much sex in it and
we can't make it - we can't make a
statement with this movie and it's seem
like what can you make at it and it
seems like the whole point of what makes
Anastasia so drawn to Christian is the
sexual undertones is they can feel did
that like lust and that and then the
lust is and describing great detail in
the book especially when they're like
[ __ ] each other here when I watch the
movie or you
cramsey fifty shades darker yet I think
if we're gonna watch a movie about a
toxic relationship I like there to be
some part of me that's like I'm you guys
see why she's involved yeah think about
the first movie was like I saw the first
movie and it was like the first half
hour went by and I was like okay I get
this situation and there was a whole
other hour where we're just waiting for
her to reach the conclusion she finally
reaches by the end of like the movie
ends that I've heard they changed the
ending from the book a little bit where
she just kind of leaves yeah this
situation isn't good for me I'm leaving
that's probably the best way you could
have ended that so I'm almost kind of
bummed that they have to make another
one cuz yeah the first movie just seems
like a whole lot of time and effort
spent for this woman to finally figure
out oh yeah I shouldn't be around this
guy yeah I don't know whether like
masculine making this all masculine I
could change Beyonce to you know they
got a male director male right like I'm
not the kind of viewer who typically
goes into a movie like okay prove it to
me Lee you have to win me over I kind of
feel this is like about this movie the
same way I would feel about Christian
Grey crawling back to me I'm like you
better [ __ ] prove that this is worth
yeah because I don't think it is yeah
and right now it just seems like he's
the same exact dude yeah he looks the
same he looks me demeanor everything
about him seems like he's exactly the
same guy good hey there's probably more
context in the movie like it's just a
trailer but I get the same vibe off of
most everything in this trailer and I
don't get that interesting of a vibe
above or below the line like the first
movie played to me fine with some laughs
this trailer starts off would say forget
the pass in the tagline and then they
proceeded to show us a trailer that's
very reminiscent of the past the whole
time I don't know I don't want to [ __ ]
about this movie yeah I mean at the end
of the day this isn't for us and you
know I doubt it matches our tasters that
we'd like it we didn't read the book
we're not fancy so like if you're really
into this what do you think you know
yeah if you're fifty Shades of Grey fan
if I can tell tell us what your thoughts
are I'm not objecting against the book
I'm not judging the book at all Beezus
I'm not judging the book at all
I'm just Rick Lee judging the film's
context and what I've seen so far yeah
anyway like this video you can subscribe
and John Twitter handle and Instagram
reasons to GRE so much to promote about
you it's annoying
I'm all over the place mister calm /
bloom house and the real rejects and I
want to give shout out to shake change
the green youtuber little of [ __ ] love
him he makes wonderful fantasies a
hilarious dude I could see CheY being in
a relationship like this yeah I could
see Shane being like very dominant kind
of manipulating an innocent girl and see
like some submissive relationship this
is the che kind of personality I get she
check out his channel and tell him that
I said that yeah
climbing to him that I said that I could
see him being borderline domestic
abusive boyfriend I've always wanted to
be spanked by Shane or like you know
lightly flogged by Shane this is just /
thank you 50 shades of gray or 50 shades
of shade what are you going I couldn't
stop turning my head